[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est le
débrief des questions au gouvernement de
ce mardi 5 mai 2020 à moins d'une
semaine du déconfinement la date du 11
mai était dans toutes les bouches
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle mais
déjà l'heure est au premier bilan sur la
gestion de crise du gouvernement
écouter christian jacob président des
républicains tout le monde comprend le
doute et le doute est légitime lorsqu'il
précède la décision mais les
approximations les ordres et les
contreurs de vos ministres
les controverses entre eux et parfois
même à votre égard sont de plus en plus
insupportable nous pleurons à ce jour
trois fois plus de morts que l'allemagne
pour un nombre de malades similaires
notre produit intérieur brut chute
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus fort
que chez la plupart de nos voisins
et lorsque l'on demande aux peuples
d'europe s'ils sont satisfaits de
l'action de leurs dirigeants
le jugement est cruel merkel comptait
courte johnson tous font mieux
ma question est donc simple sur le
premier ministre pourquoi ces mauvais
résultats
et quels enseignements en tirez vous
vous dites que les populations estime
par exemple que le premier ministre
britannique a beaucoup mieux géré que la
situation qu'en france peut-être sans
doute c'est un point de vue et je crois
qu'à la fin car un moment nous pourrons
regarder dans le détail avec la sagesse
de du regard rétrospectif et avec
l'ensemble des données
comment notre système de soins s'est
adapté à la crise et comment celui des
pays comparables soumis aux mêmes stress
soumis aux mêmes pressions a réagi je
vous dire monsieur le président jacob
j'attends ce jour avec sérénité non pas
du tout avec bravoure ou avec un
quelconque enthousiasme mais j'attends
ce jour avec sérénité
j'observe que le système italien qui a
souvent été décrié à tort car vous savez
comme moi que la lombardie qui a été la
plus marquée par cette épidémie est une
région riche une région remarquablement
équipée y compris en matière de services
publics et humains y compris en matière
de services publics sanitaires et bien
ce qu'on observe c'est que
système italien confronté à cette
terrible épidémie s'est retrouvé dans
une situation où il a dû effectuer le
fameux est terrible le tri des malades
s'agissant de l'entrée en réanimation ce
qui n'a pas eu été le cas en france dans
quelques jours les élèves de primaire et
de maternelle retrouveront le chemin des
écoles mais pour sébastien jumel député
communiste de seine maritime
la date de la rentrée intervient trop
tôt et les établissements n'ont pas le
temps de se préparer
les mères seules face aux inquiétudes de
la population sur les conséquences
possibles du coc vide chez l'enfant
reçoivent une semaine avant le début du
déconfinement un protocole certes
complet mais technocratique inapplicable
faute d'une véritable concertation en
amont des conditions ne sont pas réunies
pour une reprise à la date
inventé par le président de la
république et vous le savez beaucoup de
questions attendent des réponses cantine
transports scolaires des infections
accueil périscolaire qui fait quoi
comment chaque jour et avec quels moyens
pour les collectivités je pense que ça
n'est pas très honnête de jouer avec les
émotions sur un tel sujet nous avons
besoin d'avoir un peuple uni autour de
son école aujourd'hui il ya des peurs
certaines sont légitimes d'autres sont
cultivés par des personnes qui cherchent
à faire encore plus peur
je pense que ça quand on aime l'école de
la république on ne fait pas ça
aujourd'hui l'immense majorité des
mairies jouent le jeu en réalité et même
certains qui ont signé l'appel de ce
week-end en réalité vont ouvrir
c'était le cas de certains que j'ai vu
ce matin je ne les citerai pas dans le
morbihan par exemple j'en parlais avec
un député toutes les mairies toutes les
communes vont ouvrir sauf une
donc aujourd'hui le vrai travail de fond
il est en train de se réaliser
alors je sais bien que vous parlez vous
parlez de salons dorés moi je parlerais
de votre salon doré celui ont fait des
commentaires négatifs alors que des tas
de choses positives se passe sur le
terrain par des gens qui se retroussent
les manches des gens qui reconnaissent
la valeur de l'école de la république et
qui ne défendent pas l'école de la
république
quand les temps normaux l'instant il n'y
a pas de vagues et dès qu'il ya une
crise joue avec l'école de la république
en disant qu'elle n'est pas
indispensable aujourd'hui l'école de la
république est plus indispensable que
jamais ce serait beaucoup plus simple
pour moi de dire qu'on doit la fermer
jusqu'à jusqu au vaccin
eh bien je pense que non il faut ouvrir
parce que j'ai des préoccupations
sociales
peut-être plus ancrée que les vôtres et
cette réouverture des écoles préoccupe
de nombreux maires qui ont la
responsabilité
ces établissements dans leur commune
faut-il alléger leurs responsabilités et
faire évoluer la loi pour mieux les
protéger
c'est la question de jean pierre
cubertafon député modem de dordogne
nous devons préciser pour tous les
maires les questions qui restent
incertaines enfin de les sécuriser
juridiquement
ainsi monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous nous confirmer que le
pouvoir d'ouverture des écoles revient à
l'état le rôle du maire étant de
vérifier que les conditions fixées par
le protocole sanitaire sont remplies et
d'assurer la bonne gestion de leurs
personnels municipaux dans un objectif
de réassurance des élus il me paraît
cependant souhaitable de clarifier les
textes existants dans la loi il me
semble en effet important de prendre en
compte et les compétences propres de
chacun des décideurs et les
connaissances personnelles dont il
dispose au moment où se passent les
événements c'est un préalable qui
s'impose dans la recherche d'une
éventuelle responsabilité pénale dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire comme vous
le dites il est important en effet de
lever toute incertitude pour l'ensemble
des décideurs les élus mais pour
l'ensemble des décideurs face aux
responsabilités face aux décisions
qu'ils doivent prendre pendant cette
période de crise du colis de 19 mais il
est également essentiel et vous l'avez
également très bien rappelé que cette
évolution législative s'inscrivent tout
d'abord dans le respect du principe
constitutionnel d'égalité
il est aussi tout à fait essentiel en
évitant un risque pénal excessif que ces
dispositions traduisent l'equilibre qui
doit nécessairement exister entre la
responsabilité et la prise de décision
c'est en ce sens que je suis prêt à
travailler avec le parlement il ya
quelques jours le gouvernement annonçait
une page internet sur son site intitulé
d un fox coronavirus référençons des
articles qui luttent contre les fausses
informations une initiative dénoncée par
de nombreuses rédactions
la page sera bientôt supprimée
ecoutez-le échange du ministre de la
culture avec frédéric dumas député
liberté et territoire compte tenu la
chute de confiance des français dont la
capacité du gouvernement à gérer la
crise et à délivrer des informations
fiables
non seulement les français qui doutent
iront jamais sur un site gouvernemental
pour démêler le
du faux mais le risque est grand
d'inciter la population à s'informer en
dehors des sources me soit disant en
valeur par le gouvernement par ailleurs
cette initiative intervient après la loi
dite fait qu news ou encore la loi sur
le secret des affaires qui pose la
question la liberté d'expression et de
la capacité des journalistes à mener
librement leurs investigations
elle fait également écho à la volonté du
président de la république je le cite de
certifier déontologiquement les organes
de presse concrétiser en décembre
dernier par l'idée d'un conseil de
déontologie journalistique et de
médiation je vous demande donc si vous
allez prendre la décision de simple bon
sens qui s'imposent de supprimer
immédiatement cette rubrique du site sur
le site du gouvernement qui n'a pas lieu
d'être
quelles que soient les circonstances et
qui dépend de vous bien évidemment le
service qui était proposée par le porte
parolat qui visait simplement à apporter
un service supplémentaire pour regrouper
sous une même page les disposent les
ressources de lutte contre les des
informations concernant la crise
sanitaire ne représentait évidemment pas
un objectif de tri de d'articles ou
d'information pour autant je peux
comprendre les inquiétudes qui ont été
suscitées par ce service dans les
rédactions
parce qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas
pour l'état de labelliser les médias ou
d'orienter le choix des français vers
tel ou tel média en tant que ministre de
la culture garant de la liberté de la
presse
garant de son indépendance et du
pluralisme de la presse je souhaite donc
vous annoncer que le gouvernement a pris
la décision de retirer cette page du
site du gouvernement
voilà pour le débrief des questions au
gouvernement la semaine prochaine
l'assemblée nationale entame elle aussi
sondé confinement le nombre de députés
présents dans l'hémicycle passera de 75
à 150 élus et nous on se retrouvera pour
un nouveau débrief